[MUSIC PLAYING]
SASCHA PRUETER: Hey, everyone.
Wow.
[APPLAUSE]
Didn't do anything.
Already got applause.
It's a pretty good start.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SASCHA PRUETER: [LAUGHS] I
see a lot of familiar faces.
But the stage is getting
bigger every year.
So hey, my name
is Sascha Prueter.
I'm on the product
team for Android TV.
BENJAMIN BAXTER: I'm Benjamin
Baxter, DevRel for Android TV.
SASCHA PRUETER: And thanks
for joining the Android TV
session at Google I/O. The
session is called What's New,
but we're also talking
a little bit what
has happened in the last year.
So thanks for joining.
And yeah, let's get going.
So last time most of us talked
was last year at Google I/O.
And the Android TV
ecosystem since then
has grown significantly.
And we are, obviously,
really happy about that.
So we have now more
than 100 partners
working with us on
Android TV devices.
And as you can see, we
are doubling that, so far,
every year.
And as you can see,
the growth comes
from a number of devices
and device categories.
We have-- maybe you heard
at CES earlier this year--
a bunch of new partners in
very different smart TV price
categories launching
Android TV devices.
So we are in the
very lucky position
that we can't even list all
partners on one slide anymore.
So if you're here,
if you're working
with us on Android TV devices
and your logo is not here,
sorry.
We are running out of space.
But also in the
set-top box space,
and specifically when it
comes to pay TV operators,
we see significant growth.
And we're very happy about that.
So we already have, I think,
around 30 partners worldwide--
so pay TV operators, cable,
satellite, IPTV, shipping boxes
with Android TV.
And we have more than 50
additional ones coming.
So we are really happy.
And we see good growth there.
But it's not only
about hardware,
it's also about software.
And that's why I'm really happy
that the TV app ecosystem is
growing significantly as well.
And I think this is the fifth
time I said significantly,
so I will stop doing that.
But all of you are
contributing to apps.
Having developers here at
I/O over the last few years
actually pick up Android TV and
build cool media experiences,
games or completely new
stuff we didn't think about,
is really awesome.
When we started
the TV Play Store,
I think, in 2014, we
had 25 apps or so.
Now we are approaching 4,000.
And the thing, because there are
a lot of app developers here,
we wanted to
mention, because it's
a little bit under the
radar, we have also
launched DCB on Android TV.
A lot of you, if you're
developing for mobile,
you know direct carrier
billing already on mobile.
So if someone buys an app, if
someone does an in-app purchase
or buys a cool
new car in a game,
you can charge it to your
mobile bill in a lot of cases,
if you don't have a
credit card or you don't
want to use the credit card.
And the same concept has
launched also since last Google
I/O on Android TV.
And we're working with more and
more partners, pay TV operator
partners, that you can do
charges from the Play Store
or the Play ecosystem in
general to your cable,
or satellite, or TV
subscription bill.
But then also, one
of the things we
have started putting
more emphasis on
is the Google Assistant.
You heard us briefly
talking last year
at Google I/O about this.
And since then, the
ecosystem and the services
that the Google Assistant
brings to Android TV have--
not only to Android TV,
but to devices in general--
has grown.
So we see a lot of use
of the Assistant on TV.
We think it's a
great additional tool
to make use and consumption
of media services and apps
a lot easier on TV by just
interacting with voice--
discovering content by
simply talking to your TV,
having a very natural interface,
not having to remember,
what was that
search phrase again?
Just natural.
And it's easy, and it works.
But it's not only
about finding content,
it's also about looking
up answers to questions
you might be interested in.
It might be who that actor is.
Or it's also control of
other devices in your house.
The Assistant on Android
TV gives you all of that.
And so because we think
it is so important,
we are this year putting
a lot of priority
on getting the Assistant
into more countries.
We want to make
sure we do it right,
so we don't want
to rush anything.
But since we have launched
in the US in late 2017,
we are [? bringing ?]
this year, as you can see,
a lot more countries
into the Assistant
ecosystem on Android TV.
But even if you are in a country
or a language that is not yet
Assistant enabled and you
have to wait a little bit,
we refresh our voice
search experience
even in those countries.
So I mentioned
earlier that we are
really happy about all the
apps and more and more apps
in the Play Store.
And we, last year
here at Google I/O,
gave you a little bit of a sneak
peek of the new Android TV home
experience, and the
system UI, and how
apps can integrate with that.
Back then, it was a sneak peek.
It was a preview.
It has launched
with Android Oreo.
And we now have a lot of
partners starting to roll this
out to Android TV devices.
So we thought it's
a good opportunity
to go into more detail
how your apps can actually
take advantage of this
content first experience
that we are trying to
achieve with Android TV.
And Ben is going to
talk a little bit
about what it actually means
to have a content first app.
BENJAMIN BAXTER: Thanks, Sascha.
So we really wanted to
redefine this experience,
wanted to be very content
first, content-driven.
If you're familiar with
the previous screen,
we have one row for
recommendations, a double row
for apps, double row for games.
We've changed that, as
you can clearly see.
So apps are still important.
We have one row for apps.
It's just your favorite apps.
Your users can customize and
add your app to this row.
It's up to the
user's discretion.
That recommendation row
from Android N and below,
we've broken it up into several
different responsibilities.
So we have a Play Next row
where you can add content.
And we'll talk more
about this later,
but you can add content to
be picked back and engaged
with the user later.
The next thing we did
was we broke out--
and each app can have
their own channel.
They can have their own
surface on the home screen.
We're trying to really push
this content first design.
And every app can
contribute to it.
As Sascha mentioned
earlier with the Assistant,
the Assistant is also
on the home screen.
It's not specific to
Android O or Android P.
It's actually supported
from Android M and above.
So this is here to enhance
search and keep pushing
that content first design.
OK.
I keep saying content first.
It's like my favorite
phrase all of a sudden.
But let's look at some
really good examples
before we dive into the
technical details about what
builds a content first design.
So here, we have
Google Play Movies.
And this is from
the home screen.
And you can see everything
about their details.
It's as if the
movie detail screen
is right there on the home
screen to help build and engage
an experience.
This is great for users.
They don't have to go into
the app and hop back out.
They can make decisions right
there from the home screen.
If we take it a step further,
we have video previews.
So if you have a
movie, a trailer
makes a great video preview.
If you're an audio
app, 10-second clip
is a great audio preview.
We've found that
having previews is
very engaging for users
and drives engagement
into your app.
I said earlier about
the Play Next row.
This is a great
place for you to add
content to bring users back in.
If you're watching
a really long movie,
you add a little
bit extra metadata,
we'll make a beautiful progress
indicator to add more context.
And the users are able
to hop back into the app.
And I said channels.
You're not just limited to one
little row in the home screen,
you can have as many
channels as you want.
If we look here, we have
channels like Featured,
Top Free.
These are great channels that
you know are going to be fresh.
These have indications of being
updated daily, even hourly.
OK.
So now that we have a
nice context about what's
on the home screen, let's
dive into how you guys can
build this experience.
So what is a channel?
A channel is just
a logo and a name.
That's all it is.
It's a container for programs.
This is going to
be where you theme
your content and customize
everything deeper
in the programs.
To build a channel, we
have a support library.
It just uses the
builder pattern.
Super easy, super
convenient for you.
Everything on the home
screen should be clickable.
So if you click on a logo, it
should open back into your app.
So just set the App
Link URI, and this
will let you open up your
app from the home screen.
The next thing that's important
is the internal provider ID.
This is an ID for your app to
tell the home screen, hey, keep
track of this.
I know what this ID is.
And when I go to query
my channel later,
I can synchronize my channel
with what the home screen knows
about my app.
And that's it.
It uses a content provider.
And we have convenient methods.
For those of you that know
the joys of content providers,
you know that there can
be boilerplate code.
We've abstracted all of that
into the support library.
And we make it really easy for
you to build a content provider
API.
Those also familiar
with content providers
know that URIs are kind
of tedious and cumbersome
to manage.
The support library manages
all of that for you.
It's just a simple
insert statement,
and you get back a channel ID.
Like I said earlier with
internal provider ID,
you can use the channel ID
and the internal provider
ID to make sure,
when you synchronize
and update your
channels later, you'll
have all the keys you need.
OK, channels, like I said,
they're just a shell of a row.
The programs are
what really matter.
So let's look at an
example of a program.
In this program, we have a
bunch of stuff happening.
We have a thumbnail image.
We have a title, a description.
And anything else you
know about this program
can be added to the home screen.
The more metadata you add,
the richer the experience,
the better the user engagement.
So anything that's
in your Details page,
it's perfectly natural
to put on a home screen.
Again, builder pattern.
This time, you want to set
the channel ID on your program
so the home screen knows where
to put it on the home screen.
And if your program has more
than one channel it can be in,
make sure to add a
unique identifier.
The home screen will look at
this identifier and say, hey,
we already know about this
program on this channel.
And it's also on this channel.
We can have deduping
logic so that the user
doesn't see duplicates and adds
a cleaner, smoother experience.
You also want to set the type.
In this example, we
set the type to MOVIE.
But the type will drive
the metadata that's
shown on the home screen.
And I showed you with Red
Bull earlier, video previews.
It's as simple as
just adding a URI.
So you just say, hey,
my video preview's at
https//www.myvideo.com.
And the home screen will
play the video for you.
It uses ExoPlayer
under the covers.
So all of the supported video
formats from ExoPlayer are
supported for you
out-of-the-box.
If you have DRM or you have
a bit more complex use case,
we do support a
solution where you can
draw your video on a surface.
Come see us in Office
Hours tomorrow,
and we can go in more
depth about that.
This looks very
similar to channels.
You know, you convert
them to content values.
And then from your content
values, you'll need the URI.
The URI is dynamic,
since you're trying
to insert a program
into a specific channel,
so use the support library.
After you insert, you'll
get back a program ID.
Now your program
is in the channel,
and you have a program ID,
and you have a channel ID.
You have all the tools you need
for synchronizing, updating,
and deleting later, when you
go to update your content.
OK, I told you how
to make the channel.
Just use the builder pattern,
add it to the content provider.
But when do you make it?
When is very important.
We put a lot of time
trying to figure out
how to get you started.
And so we ended up
with a new intent.
So there's INITIALIZE_PROGRAMS
that will get triggered.
And this can happen
before your app
starts, which isn't a bad idea.
Your app just gets downloaded
onto a TV, or it gets updated.
And all of a sudden, you have
content on the home screen.
Great entry way for users
to come into your app.
So just listen for this
INITIALIZE_PROGRAMS,
and just set up your channels
and start your process.
OK, the last thing we talked
about was the Google Assistant.
I think the Google Assistant is
a pretty fantastic experience.
It pushes that content
first approach even further.
Things you can do to
integrate the Google Assistant
is to implement search,
support deep links,
and handle playback controls.
So let's look further.
When you perform a search
with the Google Assistant,
the Google Assistant keeps
this content first design--
search for my favorite
movie, "Big Buck Bunny."
Hope it's your favorite too.
And you'll see a bunch of
information-- the thumbnail,
the description, the title.
And if your app
matches, you know,
if it matches on the title,
duration, year, at the minimum,
with the metadata
returned, it will show up
in the list of apps
that it's available on.
How do you match this?
What happens under the covers?
We use more content providers.
This time, your app is providing
data to the Google Assistant.
The Google Assistant will
just pass a URI for you
to perform your search on.
In this content provider, you
can do whatever you want--
local database
calls, network calls.
Whatever you need to do
to perform your search,
you can do it.
This URI contains
the raw search string
from the Google Assistant,
but it will be sanitized.
So if you say something
like, play "Big Buck Bunny,"
it's going to send
you "Big Buck Bunny"
and realize that
Play is a command.
So just be cognizant
that the URI you get
is going to be the key for
what you should search for.
OK, controlling
playback-- if you guys
are familiar with Media Session,
you don't have to do anything.
Your app already supports it.
But we'll just
take a closer look.
If you want to support
the Google Assistant
and do different commands while
watching shows, for example,
hey, Google, pause the
movie, in your app,
you just implement
Media Session,
supply a callback with this
function onPause or onPlay.
And the Google Assistant
will trigger that
through Media Session.
onPause, onPlay-- yeah, you can
just hit the Pause/Play button
on the remote.
Maybe not the most useful
feature, but it's there.
And it's actually a
really cool experience.
My favorite one is onSeekTo.
You just say, hey, Google,
fast forward five minutes.
And the Google Assistant
actually does the math
and says, hey, your Media
Session has a state.
I know the current
position in that state.
You said, fast
forward five minutes.
That's 300 seconds, so I'm
going to send the new position
to your app.
If you're familiar
with Media Session,
you know that there's
onRewind and onFastForward.
You should still
implement those methods.
But the Google
Assistant ignores those
since it already does
the math to figure out
where to send the user to.
This next one is more
useful for audio apps
more so than video apps.
But if you say, hey,
Google, play the next song,
or OK Google, go back and
play the previous song,
all you have to do is just
implement onSkipToNext
and onSkipToPrevious.
So to recap, what are some of
the best practices on the home
screen?
You should listen for
INITIALIZE_PROGRAMS.
This is the gateway for
creating your programs
and building that experience
on the home screen.
When it comes to metadata,
you cannot have enough.
The more metadata
you add, the richer
the experience, the better
engagement from users.
Keeping on that theme of
engagement, add previews.
It's going to really
drive engagement and build
a nice experience for users.
Keeping content fresh--
if you have stale content,
you might lose trust with users.
If you have a channel
on the home screen
and you haven't updated
it in a year-- you know,
once the user watches
all those programs,
they don't have too much
of a reason to go back in.
So you want to keep
that content fresh.
And that depends on your app.
If you're an app like
YouTube or Haystack
and you have user
curated content,
maybe update every
couple of hours.
If you're an app like
Google Play movies
where the content's
already controlled,
maybe update once a day
or twice a week or so.
The goal is to keep the content
fresh so users have something
to engage with everyday.
And when it comes
to the assistant,
the Media Session
is your friend.
Anything you want to do
with Google Assistant,
Media Session is the key.
The good news is, all of
this stuff, you can do today.
It's live on Android
O. And I'm going
to turn it back over to
Sascha to talk about things
you guys can do in the future.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SASCHA PRUETER: Thanks.
Thanks, Ben.
It's interesting to see
also the different reactions
in the audience, like some
people taking notes, and taking
photos, and discussing
the code slides,
and other people like, dude,
just launch some devices.
So we'll talk a little
bit more about what's new.
You heard this morning already
from Dave Burke and some others
what's the new stuff on
Android P. And of course,
Android TV will also get some
new additions in Android P.
So I will only highlight a
few areas we're investing in.
One is definitely performance.
We have done a lot
of work in Android P
to actually make Android TV
perform better, faster, even
on entry level hardware.
So even on some of the very
affordable smart TVs you might
have seen or set-top
boxes, we want
to make sure everything's
zippy, its fast.
And we have invested a
lot in that in Android P.
And as a developer, some
things to take a look at
is think about your app
and your app behavior.
Is there maybe something, like
some animation, some feature,
you might want to disable or
tweak on low memory devices?
We see that's one of the most
common problems for some apps
on entry level hardware.
So take a look at
the isLowRamDevice
and tune your app
behavior to that.
Play around a
little bit with it.
Maybe it's some
tweaks to animations.
Or maybe on certain
devices, disable
animations or take a
look at certain features.
Also, use the Memory Profiler
to really check your app profile
and see where it might
run into some bottlenecks,
because we see that still
being some of the most
common behaviors that an app
suddenly has a drop in FPS.
And also, then,
use Android Vitals
to monitor the performance
of your application.
But again, you should see
Android P on Android TV devices
perform much
faster, much better.
And we will see more devices
because of the reduced hardware
envelope.
But we also obviously wanted
to update some things for users
and make it even easier to get
to a fully set up Android TV
experience.
I mean, let's be honest.
Not everyone enjoys necessarily
setting up a new device.
And we wanted to make
the whole experience
from un-boxing the device to
have everything readily set up
be a lot easier, faster.
And you don't have to
deal a lot with it.
So in Android P, the
whole set up process
is a lot more streamlined.
I think we reduced
the overall time
it takes you to go through
there by almost a third.
And we also have some
additional cues in there
where the phone
integration is better.
If you have an
Android phone, you
will get setup
notifications so you
can transfer account details.
For example, your
Google account,
you can easily transfer
that to the TV.
Also, we have improved
the browser sign-in
for non-Android devices.
So iOS devices or maybe a
laptop, we improved that a lot.
It's a lot faster.
It's a lot easier.
And so we should get you
through setup a lot easier.
But that's only setting up
the device with your account
and making sure all
the settings work.
What you also want on a
smart TV or an OTT box,
you also want all
your apps, right?
You want all the content.
So as part of the
setup process, we also
have the next generation
of Play Auto Installs.
And we already
recommend you apps
that you have installed on
other Android TV devices,
on past Android TV devices,
or maybe on your phone,
if a corresponding
TV app exists.
So we automatically
suggest that to you
as part of the setup flow.
And you can select there,
yes, I want all these apps.
Or maybe say, oh, I
want only a few of them.
Just a few clicks,
check boxes, you say go,
and everything is being
downloaded and installed
automatically.
No more manual
search in the Play
Store after you have
set up a new device.
But downloading and
installing an app
is only one piece that
we wanted to optimize.
What's also not a great
experience is going into an app
and then discovering that you
have to sign in with a username
and password and having
to awkwardly enter
that with your remote control.
And so that's why we're
introducing also Autofill
with Google on Android TV.
So if you have ever
entered your credentials
on one of these apps on
another Android device,
we're automatically
suggesting those to you.
Just say, yes, and all the login
credentials are being added.
You're logging in automatically,
without entering any usernames
or passwords.
So that's setup.
But also, one of the areas
where we saw a lot of users
spend a lot of time in searching
for stuff and, obviously,
not really enjoying
it, is settings, right?
Sometimes, you need
to tweak stuff,
or you have skipped a certain
setup step when setting up
your new device, or you want
to change your audio settings,
or add a different account,
or something like this.
And we have revamped
settings on Android TV
to be a lot more streamlined,
a lot less cluttered.
And we will automatically
suggest to you settings
we think you are looking for.
And for example, when you
skipped account log-in,
we, as you see in
the animation here,
will already highlight that.
Or when we saw you tweak
around with some apps,
and something wasn't right,
and you go into Settings,
we will maybe highlight
the app setting for you.
We want to make it as
easy to quickly get
in, get the stuff tweaked
you need, and get out again.
So there was a lot about Android
P. You can download the Android
P preview SDK.
And you can play around
also with the TV emulator
and try it out.
There are some other
neat things in there,
for example, external
camera support.
So you could start
writing camera apps for TV
if you want to.
So you can start
playing around with it.
We're also going to release
a lot more documentation
around the performance aspects
of TV apps in the near future,
but we wanted to talk
about two more things.
I mean, we talked a lot
about software so far,
but we also thought about what
are cool hardware experience,
what are cool devices
that could expand
the experience in
the living room?
And one of the questions
we ask ourselves
is, how would a really
cool living room
experience with a device
being the center, the hub
of the living room with
Assistant integrated, very
easy to use, controlling
all my other devices,
and bring me the best Android TV
experience onto my TV screen--
how would something
like that look like?
And the outcome of
that, the answer to that
was something like this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hey, Google.
Turn on the TV.
Play the Clemson
football game on ESPN.
- OK, what's it called again?
Curiosity?
Opportunity?
- Hey, Google.
What's the new "Star Trek" show?
- Here is some information
about "Star Trek, Discovery."
- Discovery.
- Hey, Google.
Show me potato battery
videos on YouTube Kids.
- All right.
Here's potato battery
videos on YouTube Kids.
[CHEERING]
- Hey, Google.
How long is college
football overtime?
- According to Wikipedia, it
is commonly 10 minutes long.
- This is good.
- This is really good.
- Hey, Google.
Buy more kettle corn.
- Here's what I found
on Google Express.
- I meant the show.
- I know.
- Hold up.
Hey, Google.
Dim the lights, turn off the TV,
and play some music on Pandora.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Ooh.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SASCHA PRUETER: So as you
might have seen already,
starting yesterday on
some media outlets,
we announced, together
with our partner JBL,
the JBL Link Bar,
powered by Android TV.
It's an awesome sound bar.
It has Google
Assistant integrated.
And because we put farfield
microphones into the device,
you don't even need to
pick up the remote control.
You just sit on the sofa,
start talking to the device,
and can control the
whole experience.
It has really awesome sound.
There will be an
optional subwoofer
that you can order
with it as well.
And what I think a
really cool feature
is are the three HDMI-ins.
And you might think,
well, why is that so cool?
You really can control your
whole home entertainment
experience with this.
Because a lot of you
might have actually--
well, you might have a
Playstation or an Xbox, right?
Or you might still have
that Blu-ray player,
or whatever other, or
maybe that cable set-top
box you still really like.
So you can connect all these
devices to the JBL Link Bar,
and then use the
Assistant to control--
for example, you want to
switch to the Playstation,
and it just magically happens.
And also, if-- let's
say you're playing
a game on the
Playstation, and then you
have a question
for the Assistant.
You just ask the Assistant,
and the Assistant can answer,
can show you the answer cards
over your current HDMI input.
So it's not just a
pass-through HDMI.
These are active inputs.
And it really
shows you the power
of the Assistant and Android
TV as a living room platform.
And the other cool
thing here is that we're
working to get this into a
speaker-only mode as well.
Because sometimes, you don't
need the TV screen, right?
To listen to audio,
to listen to music,
to maybe just ask
something, really,
turning this down into a
very low key smart speaker
is also cool.
So this device can do
all of those things.
And maybe sometimes
you just want
to send some music via Bluetooth
or a cast audio to the device.
Works as well.
It's your one-stop shop
for the living room.
You can control everything.
It's super easy.
It will also come
with a remote control.
But if you prefer to
just use it with voice,
well, it is really easy.
You should check it out.
We have it in our Android TV
sandbox here in sandbox C.
And ask some of the folks from
the team to give you a demo.
It's really cool.
It sounds good.
And it will launch in fall 2018.
So I said two more
things, right?
So one other thing.
We talked a lot about
Android P earlier.
And as a developer, you want to
follow all the things Ben just
told you.
And you might ask,
yeah, you told me
I can download the Android
P SDK, preview SDK, and work
with the emulator,
but I really would
like to have actual
hardware for this.
So I don't know who
of you was around
at Google I/O 2014 at Moscone
Center in-- oh, lots of hands.
OK.
Some of you were already
in Moscone in 2014.
And they might remember we
launched a device back then
to introduce Android TV.
It was called the ADT-1.
[APPLAUSE]
So we thought-- well, you
can applaud if you want--
but we thought it's time for
another developer device.
So we are introducing ADT-2.
[APPLAUSE]
So you might want to write
down that sign-up form link,
because you're the first people
to actually see this and be
able to sign up for this.
All the smartphones.
It's actually a pretty good test
for Google Lens, the actual--
BENJAMIN BAXTER: Oh, yeah.
SASCHA PRUETER: Anyway--
BENJAMIN BAXTER: If
they go to the sandbox
later and check out the sound
bar and you [INAUDIBLE],,
you'll also get an email
with this link as well.
SASCHA PRUETER: Yep.
Good point.
So this is a neat
little HDMI dongle.
It will come with
a BTLE-enabled--
sorry, a voice-enabled
remote control.
So you can try out all the
Assistant integration tips
that Ben just talked about.
It will run an Android P
developer preview release.
We will send updates
to the device.
By the way, we're also sending
updates to the sound bar.
Google, the Android TV Team
will send the system updates
and new Android versions
right through the device.
And so you can use this device
to try out all the cool things.
It's a limited edition device,
so you know about it first.
Sign up.
We will actually start to send
this out later this summer.
And it's a neat little device.
We are actually really
excited about it.
And sign up for it.
And build cool apps.
That's kind of it, already.
I said two more things.
It was two more things.
BENJAMIN BAXTER: Right.
SASCHA PRUETER: We have--
if you're working
on apps, we have
some more interesting
events that you
might be interested in.
Ben, I don't know if
you want to mention--
BENJAMIN BAXTER: Yeah.
Come visit us in Office Hours.
We have back-to-back app
reviews in Office Hours.
We're going to be, down
the road a little bit,
where the Office Hours tent is.
If you have questions,
come bring them.
If you're bored and you
still want to do TV stuff,
we have two new code labs
in the Code Lab section.
One focuses on just
the Play Next row,
and the other one focuses on
an overview of the entire home
screen.
We look forward to seeing you,
and bring your questions there.
SASCHA PRUETER: Yep.
And talking about questions,
well, obviously, we
want feedback from you.
But also, if you
have questions--
you see those microphones?
We're not using them
because of timing.
We will get shuffled
out here very soon.
But Ben and I will be over right
after this talk in the Android
TV sandbox.
Come over, talk to
us, ask us questions.
And I will most likely point to
Ben to answer those questions.
Thank you, very much.
Build cool TV apps.
And I hope we'll
see you next year.
BENJAMIN BAXTER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]